troubles present the next award for best
foreign language film it seemed only
fitting
that we obtained the services of our
next two presenters
she is the star of the searing
argentinian drama the official story
norma alejandro
he is the voice of the motion picture
industry in washington and throughout
the world
a man you've never heard of but you have
to listen to anyway
president of the motion picture
association of america here he is ladies
and gentlemen
you've been waiting for him mr jack boom
boom
while valencia still a great deal to
understand about how the new
technologies are going to affect all of
us who work in movies
one thing is already clear the miracle
of modern communication
means that people everywhere have access
to the cinema of all nations this year's
nominees
for best foreign language film are from
the federal republic of germany
angry harvest the ccc film kuntz gmbh
admiral film production
from hungary colonel reddle
a muffin objective studio manfred
dornier o r f z
d f production
from argentina the official story a
historious cinematographica cinema and
progress communications production
france three men and a cradle
a flat film production
in yugoslavia when father was away on
business of forum
film production
and the winner is
too much
god bless you the official story
accepting the award for the official
story the film's director luis quinzo
as i stand here
accepting this honor i cannot forget
that on another march 24th
10 years ago like this day
we suffered the last military group in
my country
we will never forget this
nightmare
but we are starting starting now
to begin with our
news dreams thank you
you